there are sunsets on other planets even
more spectacular than the ones on earth
what if we could see not just one but
two suns falling below the Earth's
horizon would our planet get much warmer
with two stars heating it up would we
ever experience nighttime again and
could our binary star system be able to
sustain life this is what if and here's
what would happen if we had two suns not
all star systems form around a single
star some scientists even suggest that
our Sun once had a star companion a
long-lost warf star called nemesis it
broke free of the Sun's gravity and
melted into the Milky Way billions of
years ago our search for earth-size
planets throughout the galaxy showed us
that not only our most star systems
binary but they also have habitable
zones and planets within them it looks
like the earth could sustain life with
two suns instead of just one but only
under certain conditions in a binary
star system Earth's fate would depend on
many factors from the masses of the
stars to their position relative to
earth and each other chances are high
that Earth's orbit would be very
unstable if one of the Suns was bigger
and brighter and had a much stronger
gravitational impact on us that Sun
could pull the planet towards itself we
get pretty crispy before disappearing
and it's solar flares on the other hand
if neither stars gravitational pull was
strong enough the earth would fly out
into space we'd become one of those
rogue planets that travel the universe
all alone with no star system to call
home let's assume that the Earth's orbit
would be stable this would be possible
if the earth orbited just one of the
Suns but that's no good for complex life
on the planet because at some point the
stars would face both sides of the
planet at the same time not only would
that take away our nights but it would
also bring double doses of UV radiation
and solar winds no sunscreen could
prevent you from getting toasted by two
suns
the Earth's orbit could be stable if the
planet rotated around the two stars the
stars would have to be close together
and the Earth's orbit would be further
away just how far away
most likely beyond the habitable zone
where the heat of the Suns wouldn't be
enough to keep our water in a liquid
state the planet would turn into a
frozen lifeless Rock feeling hopeless
yet well we have some good news for you
the best-case scenario for our planet
would be if we replaced our Sun with two
closely matched stars each half as
bright as the Sun this would keep our
planet warm enough to sustain life
because the total gravity of the two
stars would be stronger it would take
the earth 280 days instead of 365 to
make a whole circle around them the
distance between the stars would have to
be less than 15 million kilometers apart
that way the orbits of all the other
planets in our system would be stable
even Mercury's but let's play safe and
assume the distance between the stars
was about 5 million kilometers in that
scenario the two stars would orbit each
other once every 10 days every 5 days
one star would pass in front of another
from Earth that would look like a solar
eclipse but instead of our moon blocking
the Sun it would be one star blocking
another and instead of seven and a half
minutes that Eclipse would last for
about five hours under those conditions
the earth could be just fine orbiting
two suns the only question is whether
the earth would have formed in a binary
star system in the first place as far as
we know the smallest planet circling two
suns is a gas giant much bigger than
Earth maybe there is a small rocky
planet like Earth orbiting two suns
somewhere in the universe we just
haven't found it yet
it might even sustain life intelligent
enough to send a signal to our planet
but that's a topic for another what-if
[Music]
you